Doctor Zakir, if a person is fasting
during the month of Ramadan and
unfortunately he
passes away, he dies,
person who takes charge of his affairs
after his death, is that person obliged
to make up the fast that he's missed
during the month of Ramadan? As far as a
person when he dies
once he dies
then
all his actions they cease to exist
as Hadith of Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam it's mentioned in Sahih
Muslim volume number three
in the book of Wasaya Hadith number 4005
the beloved Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said that once a person
dies
only thing
that will continue amongst all his deeds
is the recurring charity he has made
or the knowledge that he has spread
that he has used to benefit the people
and the third is his son praying for him
so besides these three things everything
else ceases so but naturally when a
person dies
and if he had fasted maybe for 10 days
of Ramadan and dies on the 10th day
that doesn't mean that the balance 20
days somebody should make up for his
fast once he dies then he doesn't have
to offer salah he doesn't have to fast
everything ceases to exist except the
three things which I mentioned so the
person who is in charge of his affairs
he need not worry at all once he dies
everything ceases to exist except the
three things which I mentioned